serving that police Constable Jonathan
Cobham and ex-officer Joel borders was
sentenced to 12 weeks in jail for
sharing grossly misogynistic messages
they were in a WhatsApp group with
police officer Wayne cousins who would
go on to murder Sarah everard and on
this same day a police inspectorate
report commissioned after that murder
has been published and it found it was
far too easy for the wrong people to
become police officers
in Parliament MP's grilled police Chiefs
over the kind of characters getting
through the net
racially aggravated
um violence someone who'd exposed
himself seven times over a two-week
period someone who was known to be a
pimp I mean so there's clearly a big
problem as this report highlights with
the vetting there is as the report and
it's a Well evidence report identifies
in some cases a lack of compliance with
that good practice in other areas and
such as checking social media accounts
the vetting needs to be the vetting
authorized professional practice needs
to be reviewed and Rewritten and I
guarantee that I will do I will do that
within the time scale as stipulate it
the inspectorate found that hundreds if
not thousands of officers may be corrupt
violent or Predators some have passed
the vetting process despite having
criminal records or being suspected of
serious offenses or having family linked
to organized crime and all this shakes
public confidence in the police and of
course dense the morale of the vast
majority of Laura abiding police
officers
but how widespread is this culture is it
endemic in the culture of the police
there's misogyny I think misogyny is
endemic in society and the police and
the police are representative of society
but what I would say is it's more
important that we root that out in our
organization because of the role that we
have as a service and the powers that we
have
but Alice Vinton who wrote about her 10
years as a police officer says it's
those powers that can attract a certain
type it is endemic in society however I
think what the police need to admit is
that perpetrators and misogynists are
they are attracted to the power of a
warrant card until the police admit that
and encourage officers to report
anything that isn't inappropriate and
actually stand behind those officers I
don't think anything's going to change
the inspectorate has made multiple
recommendations which police Chiefs say
they will adopt in full
this misogynistic WhatsApp group that
contained a killer may have been the
extreme but it has exposed a worrying
threat among the people we expect to
keep us safe
Jason Farrell Sky News